[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler philippe
maurer économistes souverainiste proche
du mouvement des patriotes et françois
michel lambert député des bouches du
rhône bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt franges en france
françois michel lambert vous êtes le
président du mouvement liberté écologie
fraternité jérôme lefeuvre cet armateur
vous l'avez entendu espère de l'aide
d'abord votre regard sur son témoignage
recueilli par à david khalifa philippe
marras
eh bien ils ont effectivement besoin
d'elle parce que qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est que on se retrouve vous vous
donnez le contexte rapidement en fait le
problème c'est que les pêcheurs français
et notamment robert esche beaucoup dans
les eaux britanniques 770 tonnes par an
alors que les pêcheurs britannique pêche
peu dans les eaux européennes et
françaises ces 10 % de la durée de la
réciproque donc en fait ce qu'on voit
c'est une première chose des pêcheurs
français vont avoir une réduction leurs
quotas de pêche dans les eaux
britanniques à moyen terme même si les
britanniques n'ont pas été méchant là
dessus mais surtout qui dépendent en
fait du royaume uni pour pouvoir aller
pêcher dans leurs eaux hélas le royaume
uni ne donne pas des licences premier
souffre et des petites anicroches pour
mon à vue pour les empêcher de pêcher
correctement sereinement et ils sont
pris en otage on est tous créés avec en
fait mais ils sont pris en otage dans la
fin des négociations de l'union
européenne
avec le royaume uni sur le problème du
brésil on pourra en reparler d'eux
peut-être un petit peu après pour pris
en otage c'est vraiment le terme qui
convient françoise michel lombard
d'abord je voudrais saluer notamment le
pêcheur que vous avez interviewé
moi je suis écologiste et je pense que
lui les niveaux de la mise en oeuvre de
l'action a bien senti qu il réfléchit à
son propre acte de pêche il cherche à
préserver les ressources
il veut éviter justement un quine
surpêche dans certains espaces et donc
souhaitent pouvoir continuer parce que
la nature n'est pas faite de frontières
donc aller dans les espaces où il ya
moins de pression et effectivement la
situation fait que ces pêcheurs ce que
nous souhaitons défendre et bien ce sont
eux qui sont pris en otage il l'a même
dit lui-même ceux qui sont peut-être
plus gros qui ont des matériels de
traçage etc ont pu justifier de leur
présence mais le petit de petits
pêcheurs vous avez vu c'est à peine
grand comme une voiture une camionnette
ce petit pêcheur lui il est exclu donc
on est toujours dans une logique
toujours plus industrielles la france
n'a pas été à la hauteur n'a pas su les
accompagner voire je me méfie un tout
petit peu de ce gouvernement très start
up nation à privilégier ce qui était sûr
équipés de systèmes de traçage et a dit
que les baies les autres disparaîtront
dans l'histoire et bien c'est une faute
parce que ce qui va disparaître à la fin
c'est probablement la biodiversité car
tout le monde va se précipiter sur les
quelques poches qui reste alors
s'appelle cheikh qui demandent de l'aide
si rien n'est fait on ne pourra pas
vivre c'est ce qu'il nous dit il ya
urgence et ce qu'il faut revoir les
accords de pêche trouvé pour le bric
site philippe murat en fait le sujet
alors en fait ces accords de pêche sont
pas mauvais les britanniques laissent
90% des votes attache aux français dans
leurs eaux donc ce ne sont pas mauvais
en fait le problème c'est qu'ils sont
pris en otage parce que on sait que
l'union européenne a tenté pendant les
accords de l'exil de faire plier le
royaume uni même de les faire revenir
dans lions gagnent de les laisser dans
l'union européenne etc toutes les
négociations sont déroulés du bois un
peu n'importe comment et au dernier
moment où tout n'est pas parfaitement
fixé on le sait et il y a surtout un
point crucial là dedans en fait qui
n'est pas bon pour les britanniques en
fait boris johnson a dû signer il ya une
petite partie de l'accord des parents
c'est l'accord qu'il que café boris
johnson sur les frontières entre
l'irlande du nord les contrôles
douaniers entre l'irlande du nord ed et
langues r c'est à dire que l'union
européenne a tordu la main du royaume
uni là dessus pour imposer des contrôles
douaniers entre deux parties de
l'angleterre du royaume uni donc on voit
que ça pose évidemment un problème tout
cela est fait pour régler parce que il
n'y a pas de frontières entre l'irlande
du sud et l'irlande du nord irlande du
sud faisant partie de l'union européenne
l'irlande du nord de l'angleterre après
les accords du vendredi saint et l'union
européenne a voulu mettre cette épine
dans le pied ce caillou dans la
chaussure de du royaume uni mais le
royaume uni se laisse pas faire le
royaume uni on envoie du pouvoir et que
embêter malheureusement la france et
l'union européenne et il faut absolument
maintenant négocier une paix et en finir
avec cela parce qu'il ya des solutions
pour cette ces contrôles douaniers entre
l'angleterre et l'irlande une ample et
d'éviter sans humilier les britanniques
français michel lambert vous êtes
d'accord
moi je suis un peu perdu dans la
présentation - ce dont je suis d'accord
c'est que l'on se reconcentre comme nous
avons fait en méditerranée sur une
gestion partagée entre tous les acteurs
de l'espace maritime en méditerranée
peut-être on a oublié nous sommes passés
à a très très peu de l'effondrement de
la disparition du thon rouge de
méditerranée
parce que tout le monde tous ceux qui
sont autour et même des pays extérieurs
à la méditerranée venait pêcher
nous avons su trouver une coopération
internationale pour donner la place
l'équilibré chacun repoussée notamment
une partie de la course à l'armement qui
pouvait avoir lieu à l'époque ça
continuer mais certains interdiction de
technologies qui ne laissait aucune
chance au thon de méditerranée au thon
rouge de méditerranée
de survivre et aujourd'hui on peut
constater une multiplication par 3 par 4
de l'espèce en l'occurrence nous devons
avoir la même stratégie et quand on
revient sur peut-être le pourquoi de des
britanniques qui nous ferait un sale
coup à nos pêcheurs moi je préférais que
cette europe en lien avec l'europe et
communient parce que pour encore
quelques millions d'années le l'île
britannique sera à quelques encablures
du continent européen et la nature est
la pêche de la biodiversité elle elle
fait fi des frontières donc je voudrais
que l'on trouve enfin un dialogue entre
la france d' union européenne est
évidemment le royaume uni pour se mettre
d'accord et surtout favoriser les petits
opérateurs de pêche parce que ce ne
seront jamais eu qui créeront
l'effondrement de la biodiversité c'est
en tout cas le torchon brûle entre paris
et londres à propos de ces accords de
pêche c'est un sujet brûlant beaucoup de
réactions politiques à commencer par
celui qui a négocié d'ailleurs ces
accords michel barnier l'ancien
commissaire européen est devenu candidat
à la primaire de la droite regardez
les britanniques se comportent comme des
flibustiers nous allons soutenir les
pêcheurs nous allons mettre en oeuvre
tous les outils du traité que j'ai
négocié pour obliger les britanniques à
respecter leur signature
alors est-ce qu'on a véritablement des
moyens de pression philippe mora
en fait on retrouve le michel barnier
des négociations du bray dunes du
breakbeat qui disait il faut punir les
britanniques il nous faut leur faire mal
voilà des européistes et finalement dans
se retrouve un peu piégé dans notre dans
ce système là ce qui est du nera à la
france dans l'union européenne et peut
pas grand chose parce que les grandes
lignes politiques des grandes politiques
commerciales même la politique de la
pêche c'est l'union européenne qui l'a
décidée pas la france donc elle peut
demander à l'union européenne depuis
hier le royaume uni après c'est au
risque d'envenimer évidemment les
relations un peu plus entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne donc dans une
négociation à mon avis à un moment donné
il faut certes menacer le pays c'est à
dire jouer ses cartes de poker joué ses
cartes de négociations
un moment donné il faut aussi négocier
transit v et il faut pas vouloir
humilier les britanniques les obliger à
tracer une frontière entre l'irlande du
nord et l'angleterre pour faire des
contrôles douaniers alors qu'il a pas de
contrôles douaniers en europe donc à un
moment donné on reprend malheureusement
les pêcheurs sont victimes de ce système
il faut arrêter il faut maintenant en
finir avec tout ça alors françois michel
lambert comment on négocie avec les
britanniques dans ce contexte
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est michel
barnier qui s'exprime le 1er octobre
puisque c'était il ya deux trois jours
le 1er octobre sur ce sujet en dix ans
alors il n'a plus le pouvoir
en responsabilité au niveau de l'union
européenne
je crois que chacun pourra rechercher
c'est un sujet qui est quasiment depuis
le début de l'annnonce du break site sur
la table c'est ces notions et ses quotas
de pêche et ses risques de
d'exclusion de nos propres pêcheurs donc
moi je ne sais même pas quoi répondre à
celui qui était négociateur et qui dit
aujourd'hui alors que ça fait cinq ans
qu'ils aient sur ce sujet qui crée une
menace dont je n'arrive même pas à
mesurer si elle peut faire peur à des
britanniques qui sont englués dans bien
d'autres choses et d'ailleurs des
reportages précédents nom l'ont montré
donc je pense que la seule solution la
seule solution et je le redis regardons
ce qui s'est passé en méditerranée je ne
suis pas un écologiste déconnecté des
réalités regardons ce qui s'est passé en
méditerranée remémorons-nous des très
grands conflits très virulent le port de
marseille je les ai vécus bloquée par
certains industriels de la pêche etc et
bien autour de la table et autour d'une
seule réalité la seule qui doit nous
conter par la frontière pas j'allais
dire les grandes masses d'argent c'est
la réalité physique c'est la
biodiversité comment nous nous décidons
a partagé l'enjeu 2 en préserver c'est à
dire la biodiversité de cet espace je
vais revenir vers vous j'ai français
michel lambert on va regarder cette
réaction du député communiste sébastien
jumel c'était au début du mois
la france doit déposer un recours contre
cet élargissement du champ d'une pêche
destructrices qui menace les espèces et
nos artisans pêcheurs j'ai interpellé le
gouvernement pour cela françois michel
lambert est ce qu'il ya un risque
écologie si tous les européens
finalement pêche au même endroit c'est à
dire dans les eaux françaises à ce qu'il
n'y a pas un risque de voir nos
ressources naturelles s'épuisent et très
rapidement
or si tous les européens ont le même
bateau que celui que vous avez montré
dans votre reportage je ne suis
absolument pas inquiet le seul problème
c'est qu'on est dans une course à
l'armement et que
e.on on a plus de pression pour
l'instant à la façon dont nous négocions
avec les britanniques puisqu'ils ne sont
plus dans l'union européenne
avoir un fusil re un bouchon comme
michel barnier le menace mais ça ne
changera rien par contre nous pouvons
notamment avec des ong britannique au
niveau de l'europe au niveau des
contrats internationaux nous sortons de
la congrès mondial de nature où j'étais
début septembre à marseille il y aura
bientôt une coop autour de la
biodiversité
il y aura un glasgow la coop 26 sur la
question climat et la biodiversité et le
climat sont extrêmement liés donc bref
le seul point sur lequel nous devons
aller ce que dit mon collègue sébastien
jumel c'est non pas sur récit de faire
peur aux britanniques mais de revenir à
la raison de la seule chose qui doit
nous tenir compte c'est la ressource
disponible dans cet espace de pêche et
se mettre d'accord sur qui va pêcher
avec quels moyens ils refusaient la
course à l'armement pour risquer
l'effondrement de la biodiversité le
gouvernement français qui promet une
riposte on va regarder cette réaction
du secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes clément mais nous ne pouvons
plus accepter le non respect par le
royaume uni de la corde du breakbeat et
des droits garantis à nos pêcheurs avec
annick girardin nous soutenons à 100%
les pêcheurs français et nous définirons
dans les prochains jours les mesures de
réponse à l'égard du royaume uni si
l'émirat on peut faire confiance au
gouvernement
non il n'a pas les cartes en main en
fait c'est l'union européenne qui a
passé plus de cartes en main et donc qui
peut passer à grand chose effectivement
je pense qu'on peut pas leur faire
confiance sur le sujet bon on est parent
dont philippe une erreur je voudrais pas
vous couper mais mais c'est hallucinant
de de vide c'est une langue de bois
total c'est au cas vous avez raison ça
fait cinq jours la terre delhi s'est
rien passé non mais c'est et puis il n'y
a rien relisez l'intervention même celle
de michel barnier était un peu plus et
pourtant je la critique avait plus
d'ambition celle de sébastien jumel elle
était très extrêmement clair il n'y a
aucune voix qui est tracée juste une
déclaration pour essayer de faire croire
qu'ils font quelque chose et ils n'ont
aucune stratégie moi j'en propose une
c'est de travailler peut-être que c'est
pendant six mois qu'on y arrivera mais
j'ai vu que ça a marché en méditerranée
j'insiste sur la question de l'
équilibre de la biodiversité de toutes
les pêches qui peut y avoir dans la zone
qu'elle soit en zone française qu'elle
soit en zone britannique et que l'on
définisse comment on peut aller pêcher
c'est à dire qu'on refuse les usines les
bateaux usines qui viennent piller et
qu'on revienne à une pêche déquilibre
celle que nous devrions garder en tout
cas cette fois ci pas d'accord avec vous
en faites sur ce fait qu'il faut refuser
les navires-usines et avoir plutôt des
petits bateaux alors malheureusement
vous le savez l'union européenne a
laissé faire cette politique de ado plus
grand de bateaux usines mais en revanche
je dois quand même reconnaître une chose
clairement c'est que ce qui est ennemie
remplaçant de police différents pays
d'europe pour les quotas de pêche d'oran
espace d europe n est quand même quelque
chose qui a bien fonctionné qu'il ya
bien permis de préserver la ressource et
la biodiversité voire parfois de la
faire remonter mais maintenant il faut
qu'on passe entre états entre états
nations à des discussions pour avoir des
plus petits bateaux effectivement de
pêche en général dans les affaires les
plus d'emplois et moins de dégâts
philippe mora vous du temps il faut il
faut qu'on négocie entre états nation
justement ces tensions autour des
accords de pêche et bien pose la
question de la souveraineté sur nos os
justement et ça donne aussi le la aux
défenseurs du fric site votre avis
là-dessus françois michel lambert
à ceux qui disent il faut sortir
finalement de l'union européenne pour
pouvoir prendre le dessus
je cite l inverse les britanniques
seraient encore dans l'union européenne
il serait plus facile de négocier avec
eux donc si chacun repart dans son
secteur ici après la bretagne se scinde
de la normandie et la normandie se
scinde des hôtes france chacun sur cette
façade aura sa propre stratégie fera
peut-être une course à l'armement et aux
navires usines c'est tout l'un vers ce
qu'il faut je cherche et je voulais dire
à ce que puisque les britanniques de son
fils dans l'union européenne on retrouve
un point de convergence en intelligent
sur la seule réalité qui est avec nous
c'est une réalité physique c'est celle
de la nature et la nature elle fait fi
des frontières donc nous devons
retrouver un moyen non pas de se sortir
de l'union européenne mais de dialoguer
autour d'un espace maritime dont dans
lequel nous devons préserver des
ressources parce que si elle venait à
s'effondrer côté français les
britanniques en pâtirait tout autant et
inversement si elle venait à s'effondrer
du côté britannique les français et
l'union européenne les citoyens
européens en pâtir et philippe me
rassure cette question de la
souveraineté de nos zoé et le fric site
alors il faut une souveraineté mais pas
seulement pour les eaux pour l'ensemble
des sujets il faut puisque nous on peut
plus décider de notre politique dans
beaucoup de domaines l'union européenne
vient de reprendre la main vient de
prendre la main sur la politique de la
santé nos médicaments maintenant seront
décidées par l'union européenne ne
pourront plus être approuvé par le
gouvernement français on a des problèmes
partout aux très graves sur les flux
d'immigration où les directives
européennes ce regroupement familial
s'impose ce sont des lois européennes en
fait que les directives européennes un
boss de nombreux trous des clandestins
impose une absence de frontières une
absence de politique d'immigration et de
schengen nos problèmes économiques est
une monnaie qui est trop cher qui
détruit complètement note un don de
notre industrie et notre problème
agricole où les agriculteurs se
suicident tellement ils ont du mal à
vivre à cause des accords de libre
échange que si l'union européenne le
fait que la commande publique n'est pas
réservé aux entreprises françaises
contrairement à tous les pays du monde
entier et en fait elle est ouvert au
monde entier si avec les impôts des
français payent des des entreprises
chinoises allemandes américaines pour
leur commande publique alors eux ne font
pas la même chose les américains et les
chinois dans queer terme bien de
souveraineté nationale c'est une
nécessité absolue pour régler ou les
nombreux problèmes de la france qui sont
accumulées et le grès royaume uni d'où
des montrent que c'est possible mais que
c'est souhaitable on a vu que le royaume
uni a réussi à vous faire augmenter les
salaires de 8,8 pour cent cette année
des britanniques
ce qui veut dire qu'ils ont une hausse
du pouvoir d'achat de 6% al'inverse les
ascenseurs ont une baisse de poids
d'achat 2% avec une hausse des salaires
seulement de 0,6 voilà il ya un
changement radical de modèle économique
au royaume uni il faut bien comprendre
c'est une révolution thatcher à l'envers
en titane cher c'est la fin du travail
mal payé qu'a promis le boris johnson
s'est des investissements dans les
hôpitaux publics massifs et c'est la fin
de l' immigration d l'immigration
massive qui aura très peu d'immigration
et donc donc c'est un formidable à venir
cette il y demeura on va conclure c'est
aussi des pénuries en eau carburant au
royaume-uni merci domaines qui sont made
in google déjà demain c'est une
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire merci à vous qui dites maurer
économistes et souverainistes proche du
mouvement des patriotes et merci
françois michel lambert député des
bouches du rhône président du mouvement
liberté écologie fraternité 6